hello everyone welcome to another
episode of History of Science and
Technology q a
I'm happy to try and answer questions
about uh things I've been involved in or
things that I might have studied in the
history of Science and Technology
and
uh
let's see
questions here about
the discovery of logic and
relationship to modern machine learning
and things like that well gosh let's see
well let's start off with talking about
the the history of logic a little bit
so
I think the in logic dates to Antiquity
and was part of the kind of
philosophical tradition of antiquity I
think that the stoics had various forms
of logic but I think the the real sort
of official logic uh that um uh
that we know today had sort of its
starting point with Aristotle
um and the fourth Century BC I guess uh
and Aristotle's big idea was take pieces
of rhetoric somebody says you know
because Athens
is better than Sparta and this is that
therefore this
these kind of chains of argument and his
goal was to catalog trains of argument
and Aristotle was a big kind of sort of
early encyclopedias do you like to
catalog everything from forms of sea
creatures to causes of things to all
kinds of other types of of kind of
organization of information as sort of
the cataloging of things and so one of
the things he wanted to catalog was the
structure of arguments and I don't know
I don't think he invented this but but
by the time of the Middle Ages
um when Aristotle's Works were kind of
the the key works of science that were
kind of the main thing transmitted from
Antiquity in terms of science tended to
be the works of Aristotle and Aristotle
had some quite sensible things to say
and some absolutely crazy things to say
that were you know I just imagine
Aristotle one day just saying hey I
wonder how this works and saying well I
think it might work like this and he
writes it down and that becomes you know
a piece of the Canon of uh of science
for the next um the you know 1500 years
or some such
um and some of what he concluded was was
kind of crazy
um from a modern point of view and some
of it was kind of like yes that's the
obvious thing to conclude and it's good
somebody wrote it down and that was the
thing that people learned from through
the Middle Ages but
so it was with so-called soulgistic
Logic the you know the typical structure
there are these different structures of
syllogisms and they all have the form of
things like for all blah there is a blah
for all blathers a blah therefore for
all blah there's a blah and I think the
um you know famous one is um uh all men
and Mortal Socrates is a man therefore
Socrates is mortal and each of those
forms of syllogism there were like 15 of
them or something uh which are
essentially the combinatorial
combinations of for all and there exists
and so on each of those uh got a
mnemonic in in medieval times I think
famous ones were Barbara and celerant I
think were two famous uh ones and
Barbara somehow uh has the maybe it's in
Latin I'm not sure has the has the
pieces of that for all and there exists
and so on and that's kind of the
structure of of syllogistic logic is
this kind of um uh these putting
together these pieces and saying there's
this pattern
and the idea that there would be more to
logic than this kind of structural
pattern took a very long time to emerge
that wasn't until Bool in the 1830s I
guess 1830s or 1840s
um who kind of made this connection
between logic and algebra the idea that
you could actually have sort of huge
collections of logical Expressions
um much as you could have sort of huge
collections of terms and things like
polynomials you know leibniz had had
some things to say about this but I
don't think it really formulated that
same kind of sort of connection to
algebra of logic the idea that you could
take expressions in uh that were stated
things that were stated in terms of
um
in terms of words and so on and reduce
them to something formal that was like
algebra and so-called formal logic
um people like Charles Dodson AKA Lewis
Carroll
um were involved in this in the in the
mid-1800s
um Charles Johnson wrote a famous book
about logic
um and not as famous as Alice in
Wonderland
um but uh that was um uh his um
um
uh uh his
um his sort of day job was was studying
logic you know I was reminded in of the
Alice in Wonderland thing I I happened
to just be uh finding some books of mine
that I hadn't um uh seen in 50 years uh
I just opened some boxes and there were
some old books and one of them was a a
Greek to English dictionary lexicon uh
that was a the sort of the most famous
Greek to English dictionary that was a
little unscott were the were the two
authors of that and the thing that's
notable about that in connection with
what I was just talking about is Alex
little was the um uh was the daughter of
the little who wrote the um uh the
Lexicon and she was the Alice in Alice
in Wonderland so to speak uh some child
of some Oxford
Classics and other person
anyway the um but back to sort of the
progress of logic I think then this kind
of pattern of what does a valid argument
look like
is something that one sees kind of the
the syllogism idea goes through this
long period of time of people learning
Aristotle basically as a way to learn
science like things in the Middle Ages
and finally gets mathematicized with
bull
um in the in the early 1800s meanwhile
people like leibniz in the late 1600s
had had things to say about this because
leibniz for example his PhD thesis for
instance which he wrote when he was
pretty young
um was about resolving legal cases using
logic so I think his idea was you could
take a a legal case stated in some way
or another and you could apply
essentially what must have been at the
time so logistic logic to just sort of
knit the pieces together to find what
the conclusion should be so that was
kind of the um uh this idea of what
would be a valid argument and how would
that be set up it got mathematicized
with bull by the end of the 1800s it was
even more mathematicized
um as a uh and these different forms of
kind of formal logic came in so so with
bull he was really dealing with ands and
O's of knots and he was dealing with
thinking about an and like a
multiplication and or like an addition
and not like a negation these kinds of
things and you know his real sort of
breakthrough was realizing you could do
sort of sloppy algebra where one plus
one equals one so to speak
um and uh it isn't quite modular modular
arithmetic it's something a little
different it's something a little
sloppier
um but that that form of of what's now
called Boolean algebra
um could represent these logical
operations and what then happened I
think towards the um this must have been
probably in the early 1900s
the so-called modal Logics where you
would sort of tag these expressions in
different ways you'd have things like
temporal logic where you would have
things which specifically talk about
time things that instead of saying for
all oh I should have explained also uh
predicate logic the so so Bulls logic
was just ANS and O's and Knots there was
also the formalization of there exists
and for all leibniz that had
formulations of that in a sense so
logistic logic has some formulations of
that
um but the sort of the formal version of
that I think was really got love fraga's
work in the 1870s 1880s
um kind of time frame of really
formalizing what would now be called
predicate logic of of being able to say
you know for all blah for all X there
exists a y such that Etc et cetera et
cetera and resolving those kinds of
things I mean notably the one of the
things that is sometimes confusing in
the history of logic girdle in 1930
right before he did girdle's theorem the
famous girdle's incompleteness theorem
of 1931 girdle proved his completeness
theorem which was that pure predicate
logic is complete in the sense that in
pure predicate logic we just got thralls
in their in their exists you don't have
any non-trivial predicates like things
talking about arithmetic and things like
that pure predicate logic is complete in
the sense that it is a decidable theory
where you can just grind through and
resolve whether something is true or not
that's also the case with ordinary
Boolean algebra that you can just in
ordinary Boolean algebra you can
ultimately just say you know p and Q or
not whatever you know is that a
tautology is it always true for example
well one way you can resolve that is
just take your p's and q's which are
either true or false and just fit in all
the combinatorial possibilities is for
the truths and falses you make a truth
table and then you just look is it all
trues in the truth table it's a strange
thing that a truth table might seem like
an incredibly obvious idea that you
might have thought people like leibnets
or Bool for that matter would have come
up with I think it actually didn't
emerge until probably the 1930s or so
and um it was Wittgenstein for example
talks about truth tables whether that
was original to him I'm not sure Emerald
post also talks about truth tables and
we'll post was the person who um looked
at the post-correspondence problem and
the post tag systems and these kinds of
things he was involved in kind of an
early attempt to find a kind of minimal
formalization of mathematics and of
computation
um but anyways he he talks about truth
tables probably in the 1930s or so but
that idea which is the thing that sort
of shows you that standard Boolean
algebra is decidable you can just figure
out everything about it by just
enumerating all those possibilities
um that's uh uh that's that took
surprisingly long time for people to do
what would seem to me to be the sort of
obvious computational kind of thing to
do now of course the the when you when
you say well I'm going to find out
whether the thing is always true or or
another question is whether it's ever
true is there any collection of p's and
q's and so on such that this logic
expression is true that question of
whether there's ever a case where it's
true is the so-called satisfiability
problem and one question that comes up
is is there a faster way to work out
whether the answer is true than by just
substituting all the exponential in many
possibilities and seeing whether one of
them turns out to be true
well this problem of satisfiability was
a problem which in 1970s Stephen cook
um figured out was an example of an NP
complete problem a problem for which the
figuring out the answer to that is
equivalent to looking at the evolution
of an arbitrary non-deterministic turing
machine so in other words basically the
the um
uh you you can't you can't work out the
answer to this if you could work out the
answer really quickly to knowing uh is
there a an assignment of truth values
such that the thing is true if you could
work that out really quickly you would
be able to solve all NP problems in in
polynomial time you would be able to and
you would be able to do uh you know
factoring a polynomial time and all
kinds of other problems in polynomial
time but that that satisfiability thing
which is the yes and principle you can
work out the answer it's a finite
computation but it might be an
exponentially large computation in
principle but this whole question about
uh what makes kind of a valid statement
what is logically correct
that is a kind of an idea that goes all
the way back to people like Aristotle
and even the stoics before him and so on
of of kind of what are the rules of
construction that makes something true
um that makes something a valid a valid
chain of um of reasoning so to speak
it's sort of interesting that the
interplay between that and is an
equation satisfiable for example is
there a solution to the equation this
that or the other these two Traditions
have evolved somewhat somewhat connected
and somewhat disconnected the tradition
of logic and the tradition of sort of
mathematics they were they were you know
they were separate subjects people
studied in the Middle Ages for example
um they it's always a sort of an
interesting feature of history that
mathematics locked itself into the the
educational curriculum logic did not
mathematics everybody learns mathematics
very few people take a class to that
logic and Mathematics has has turned out
in a sense to be a much richer field but
for the following reason it's richer
because there's more that one can
explicitly do in the case of logic one
gets a certain distance and then one
runs into what I would now describe as
computational irreducibility and
basically you say you can't work that
out with any simple argument you just
have to do a computation and see what
happens and that's a rather non-human
thing to be having to do so I think
that's sort of why mathematics
mathematics has a lot much longer on
ramp so to speak of things that you as a
human can do before you hit some
boundary of undecidability and and
computationally reducibility a
mathematics that sort of successfully
defines itself to look at things where
that usually isn't the issue so
but any case I think this question about
sort of the making valid statements okay
why is this relevant right now okay so
you look at you know chat GPT for
example and it has this language model
which is a statistical model for the
structure of sentences and it says well
you know there is a uh this is a likely
sentence that one might have produced
and you know if you look at well
slightly more primitive versions of of
chat GPT I don't know exactly how it's
been engineered to avoid this
um but there's a you end up with
something where yes the most likely
sentence to produce is one that
eventually just keeps repeating or
something like that you have to add a
temperature parameter that kind of you
know adds Some Noise to the situation so
that doesn't happen but the uh and by
the way oh gosh this is this is such a
you know they're these kind of themes
that show up of sort of awkward
situations that show up in the history
of Science and and this is one of the
one of the famous awkward situations
it's like you say well I'm iteratively
producing words from this system I'm
producing the next word the next word
the next word at every step let's say I
pick the most probable word I've got
some whole algorithm and it ranks words
in terms of which is the most probable
and then you know do you pick that one
or do you pick sometimes to pick the
second or third most probable would you
just keep pegging it on the most
probable word
this is very similar to questions about
things like natural selection and
biology where you say okay you've got
these organisms and you're doing an
artificial version of natural selection
you're simulating natural selection do
you always pick the fittest organism or
does that lead you to a more brittle
situation is it important that the the
not quite winner be actually considered
to have a variation that can go to the
next generation is it always the case
you know if you have if if you kind of
uh select for the topist so to speak in
every
um in every generation and you only look
at variations from the top organism in
every generation do you end up with a
worse result than if you say well let me
go down to the fifth most most
successful organism and let's have a
variation of that it's kind of like like
you know you have the parents and the if
you have if you only have the perfect
parents do you get the more perfect
children or do you sometimes have to go
to the less perfect parents because A
variation from the less perfect parent
is going to lead to an even more perfect
even fitter so to speak child
um than if you went from the the uh the
sort of the the the fitter parent and
you can kind of see how this can happen
in the structure of these kind of
complicated spaces of where where
Fitness occurs but any case the the
thing that
that then is a um uh a feature of um uh
of of
so that that's kind of in these in these
statistical language models you're
saying well well make me a sentence that
is a reasonably probable sentence and
hopefully that will be a sentence that
makes sense
um and usually it seems to do a
remarkably good job of of having a
sentence that somehow makes sense
but there's sort of a question of could
can one fit together sentences that make
sense using some rules like one does
with logic logic is a way of making
sentences that make logical sense in
some sense they can be about things that
might not even exist if you say uh all
P's are a q or Etc et cetera et cetera
you might formally write that down and
be able to derive things on the basis of
the rules of logic but it could be the
case that there are no peas in the world
it's just a thing where you can formally
make the starvation but it really isn't
about anything and philosophers go to a
lot of trouble to distinguish between
things like sentences and statements you
know a sentence is just the thing you
write down that has those words in it a
statement maybe is something that you
can actually decide is true or false
because the things in it have some real
existence so to speak these are subtle
issues of philosophical logic which
people people have argued about for
centuries so to speak
um I you know for me as a as an actual
Constructor of computational language
and so on the thing that's always
interesting about those philosophical
debates is uh you know in the end one
has to write code and these
philosophical debates have a habit in my
experience and sort of dissolving when
you actually say we've got to write code
it's got to be this or that we've got to
decide what to do and then the only
question is whether the thing you decide
to do people say oh that's hopeless
that's not what I mean most of the time
it's totally confusing that's a bug in
the design that that it's a bug in the
design is kind of the modern flag for
the summer student philosophical logic
so to speak but this question of whether
one can sort of decide uh like logic
puts together a certain kind of
structure of things but without any
reference to things real things in the
world without any reference to things
which might exist or not might exist
Etc and the question is is there sort of
a semantics where one can some situation
where one can sort of feed reality into
the logic and people have tried to do
this a variety of times in the over the
course of the of the 20th century for
example with various kinds of of uh
Logics that sort of tag more things
about the p's and q's and so on and tag
whether they're probable whether they
exist at certain times and all those
kinds of things
uh in a sense Aristotle had already
started talking about this because he
starts talking about categories of
things and you know things that are
qualities things that are oh I don't
know uh maybe mental States we might
call them today things like this that
tradition of kind of uh having these
categories and then I don't think
Aristotle really got too much into what
categories can fit together with what
other categories he didn't he didn't
really do that that would have been a
sort of a generalization of his logic to
be able to do those kinds of things that
idea of sort of what categories fit with
what categories has a pretty lame
history I mean leibniz looked at it a
bit Kant looked at it a bit I think her
sorrow looked at it a bit and it had
some sort of you know some vague
presence in the 20th century there was
an I think a judo wits in the 1920s and
1930s who was trying to make kind of a
um uh an algebra out of grammar
um looked at a little bit and that that
led to what are now called com
um categorical grammars
um categorical grammars that common
um combinatory categorical grammars I
guess is the full name and that's kind
of a scheme for asking so so in a
standard grammar
a little bit like logic but of a
different character in a standard
grammar you say you fit together
sentences by having a noun a subject
noun a verb an object noun things like
this or an a subject verb phrase with
adjectives as well as nouns and so on
you're giving a very structural way of
the way that the words are assembled and
there's no guarantee that the assembled
words will actually mean anything the
famous example given by sort of the
early AI people is the phrase green
ideas sleep furiously which is
syntactically correct all those parts of
speech are right but what that means
non-poetically is very unclear uh it's
some
I think so so the question is is there
sort of a level of that that is more
semantic that is more not just we fit
any noun with any verb but we say
something about what the words and nouns
mean and that's something that uh
there's been a little bit of work done
on but not as much as you might think I
mean there was a a theory I was going to
say that the way that those grammars
were constructed one way you can think
about it is that those grandmas are kind
of like an algebraic system they have
they have rules where you say you put
this word in it's like you add another
word it's kind of like multiplying some
something or making uh words in a group
where you're taking elements of the
group abstract elements of the group and
you're just uh sort of combining them
together by what amounts to
multiplication and then you have rules
that say what are possible sequences of
of words
um sort of mathematical rules that
Define that that was an early idea
that's been reborn multiple times but
it's being even thought about these days
in terms of
categorical grammars the um
the sort of the other idea that came in
the 1950s although it had had precursors
back even in Antiquity was the idea of
kind of tree structured grammars where
you say I've got a sentence I'm going to
make this diagram where I have you know
the noun phrase the verb and I'm drawing
that as a tree and the noun phrase then
has a sub piece that's a noun and two
adjectives or something like this
uh so that is um uh uh that that that
kind of structure of of how do you put
together put thing language together
syntactically is something that has
become decently well understood in the
last 50 years or so
um it had people had written grammar
books even back in Antiquity but this
idea of a more sort of formal
computational version of how you put
that together is is a fairly modern idea
um the corresponding thing for semantics
really hasn't been done
um the uh the idea of doing that where
you are putting together things which
have only a certain meaning the closest
analogy to that is basically what I've
done in in our computational language in
most language trying to represent sort
of things in the world in some precise
computational way and then say what goes
together with what and and there again
you have kind of a a sort of an
interesting thing that I have to admit
I'm I'm still grappling a little bit
with the with the philosophical
understanding of how this all works but
you know you can syntactically put
together all kinds of things in modern
language you can take you know some City
and you can take it to the you know
multiply it by some other city and you
can add that to a star and things like
that that is syntactically valid in a
Muslim language those things exist there
they are syntactically writable down but
what that whole thing means doesn't
really have a meaning the way we
represent that in Wilson languages it
just stays unchanged it's just not
transformed in any way by the language
but then there's this notion of
evaluation that if you say what is the
population of the city you know a city
and then some population uh uh construct
there then that thing can evaluate it
has a it has a meaning which is a sort
of an actionable meaning which turns it
into something else but this idea of
what sort of our what a valid forms of
construction semantic forms of
construction we have a very well defined
no notion of that which is things that
can be resolved to other things but
there's also potentially a version of it
where one's just talking about things
that can be stated and where you can say
this is this is true so to speak it is a
relation that can be stated as true and
then other things deduced from it it's
kind of like you might assert the
equation you know X Plus y equals seven
and that's an assertion that's not
actually saying what the values of X and
Y are it is merely a certain X Plus y
equals seven is true and then you can
deduce other things from that and I
think there's a similar kind of thing
that one can do where one could say
something which is syntactic but not
semantically meaningful say that's true
but what that means to say that's true
is not very clear if I just assert you
know X Open Bracket y comma such and
such without knowing what these things
are
um I can assert that but what we can
deduce from that is not clear it's only
if the thing has a well-defined
understandable meaning that we can
expect to make a tower of deductions
from it now one of the things that's
sort of interesting is that in the case
of logic it took until the 1800s and and
beyond for people to start sort of
building from the original ideas of Anza
Wars and Knots building these kind of
towers of um uh of of of complicated
logic which we lead now to you know
microprocessors with a billion logic
gates on them things like this that
where we're making sort of deep use of
this kind of stack of logic and it's an
interesting question if we have similar
kinds of things not for sort of the pure
uh kind of unmeaningful logic but
something which is real semantic content
what that kind of looks like when you
have these giant stacks of kind of
semantic construction uh that have been
created there one of the things that I
think may happen is that us humans if
we're doing logic yeah we can handle
basic so logistic logic we can all
pretty much intuitively handle it if you
try and do something like taking I don't
know I found this simplest Axiom for
Boolean algebra back 20 years 23 years
ago now and um uh you know the proof of
that is it's very complicated machine
generated proof which is all perfectly
logic it's all just applying logic but
it's incomprehensible to humans and the
you know we might think that the
semantic chains that we would get would
be oh that'll be understandable by us
humans because it's all about things
that mean stuff I'm sure that won't be
true and that we can already see that in
the operation of programs to some extent
but I think seeing that about sort of
large-scale things about everyday life
so to speak that we can idealize and
then make giant stacks of them that's
kind of an interesting case where sort
of seeing how that really plays out will
be a little bit I I think uh interesting
how non-human that gets how quickly and
and quite possibly a lot of things that
we might say about uh well I don't know
figuring out kind of the the way that a
society Works given individual people in
it with certain kinds of sort of things
that they do and and so on and ways that
they that they respond to stimuli and so
on
um it could very well be that when we
have this kind of sort of semantic
structure that's the analog of logic
that we we may get some slightly
different intuition for how that kind of
thing works because we've only had we
haven't really had this kind of
meaningful to human sort of Stack that
we can build in a tall way from kind of
formal structures so that's something
something might happen but you know this
whole question about sort of how do you
formalize sort of meaning in a way that
is is very uh structured is something
that is as I say my efforts in
computational language are probably the
most elaborate effort so far
um that have been done I mean I think
it's it's um the the field is somewhat
Barren
um and uh you know it's kind of like uh
you jump from Aristotle to leibniz to
you know to kind of modern times and and
computational language design and so on
um the uh
I think that um that there were some
efforts in the 1600s along with leibniz
uh particularly there was a whole effort
to sort of abstract from the mere
linguistic something which people called
at the time a philosophical language
something which would represent meaning
in a way that was not tied to the
specifics of English or Latin whatever
else and there were some efforts at that
time to do that
um people were very confused about
whether the morphology you know whether
the actual writings of the language was
important to to this effort and that
made things even more obscure than they
would otherwise have been but you know
that led in the 1800s to things like
Esperanto sort of uh simplified
artificial language there was this idea
of simple English
that was I think from the early 1900s of
kind of a version of English where he
stripped down the number of uh um number
of um
uh number of words that were used and
then there were in modern times there
are all sorts of
um uh artificial languages
um uh the the um
conlangs constructed languages uh
sometimes they appear in you know movies
and such like as you know the whatever
it is doth Rocky or whatever that the
name is or or the language I think
Avatar had another had another
constructed language in it a recent
Avatar had another constructed language
in it
um and uh usually these these
constructed languages for for the movies
so to speak are mash-ups of um uh with
some modification to know and uh human
languages and so on but um I was
interested to see that chat GPT at least
as of a few days ago thought it could
translate to ithqual which is sort of
the most elaborate of the uh of the
constructed languages and I I got a line
of ithquel and I I was sending mail for
other reasons to the creator of
earthquille and so I sent him this line
of ethical and he said it was awful so
so Chachi PT didn't didn't learn how to
do conjugation of of of verbs and things
like that in earthqual which is not a
terribly big surprise and it's
remarkable that it could do anything in
in that language kind of makes me wonder
you know this this whole idea of of um
uh sort of statistical structure of
language as sort of the question of what
is the essence of what's going on in
that statistical structure of language
and is that telling one something that
is really a feature of human thought
that is something sort of abstracted
from the the mere sort of structure of
words is it something a little bit more
like logic or like General syntax that
is something that is sort of a a general
feature of how we think about things and
how we uh sort of uh generate our
thoughts as as language
um and it kind of makes me wonder you
know how what what happens when we apply
this to the whale song so to speak
um and you know is there I I would
suspect that whatever structures there
are in our brains that are relevant to
the kind of uh uh the things that we're
doing to generate language I have to
believe that those structures are
probably you know biology is is
remarkably conservative and and the
things that we have often are like oh
yeah you can recognize that from the the
Tree of Life from 100 million years ago
or a billion years ago
um you know you could these are not new
ideas in biology so to speak and my
guess is a lot of the Linguistics uh
construction kinds of things that we
have and the things that relate to
thinking as revealed in language
probably a pretty old structure so and
will exist in the whales and the
Dolphins and maybe the songbirds and
things as well
um it's uh so it's an interesting
question to me at least whether the
things that we're now seeing that are
these kind of richer statistical
structure of language that things like
chat GPT tap into whether they have a
sort of a uh you know an analog in um a
direct analog in the kinds of things
that um that happen in in other animals
and so on now you know an interesting
question I suppose is is uh you know how
would you tell well obviously the way
that something like a large language
model like chat GPT is based on works
what it's trying to do is it's trying to
learn how to continue a sentence
basically saying if you've got a
sentence that has these words up to this
point what are the likely continuations
of that and so the obvious thing which
would be an easy thing to try actually
is uh to what extent can you do that
successfully with like Wales songs and
so on to what extent can you train a uh
um a a a a
um like a Transformer net or something
like that to be able to predict what
will come next my guess is it will work
quite well now the next question is if
you do that uh to what extent can you
um
uh is there a way that you can then
imagine a translation you see what
happens in human language translation is
that you've got some
internal uh
um
internal representation within the
neural net of what amounts to sort of
the where the sentence is in meaning
space and you're you're basically saying
well I've got the sentence in English
that was characterized by this list of
numbers but the characterizes sort of
where it is a meaning space and now we
can render that list of numbers in
French or something as as uh as a
sentence in French and that's and that's
how we can think about language
translation
you know and on the subject of of sort
of the general architecture of these
kind of networks and how they relate to
human thinking I was a little bit
surprised I I have thought about this
off and on for many many years and and I
was just looking at my book new kind of
science which came out in 2002 and
there's a short section about human
thinking that's kind of tucked away in
this in the chapter about perception and
Analysis and actually it's it's I have
to say it's surprisingly sensible and uh
although it doesn't use the term
embeddings for this way of turning sort
of Concepts into numbers it talks about
hash codes because that was the closest
analogous concept that that I had at the
time it's a it's actually a surprisingly
decent description of how this stuff has
ended up working
um so I I was I was interested to see
that at least
um
but any case that that uh
um so you know the the question of
whether there is a way to uh the way
that human languages work we have this
notion of these um we can construct
these embeddings and we can uh we can
make these connections between you know
because we have parallel corpora which
say you know have a uh things in English
and things in French we can connect
together
um these these things and actually make
a translation which is something we
don't get to do for uh presumably for um
uh you know for the whale songs or
whatever else
let's see uh
other questions here
um
Zero D is commenting didn't no Chomsky
also do work in the intersection between
Math logic and language
I wondered if language models are based
on that at all
um I mean I once had a conversation with
Noam Chomsky about kind of the the
concept of creating a computational
language which was sort of a precise
representation of linguistic ideas or at
least ideas about the meaning of things
and I have to say his main position was
um you know I I'm I was saying that you
know I'm trying to create a language
that represents things in the world and
is saying but are you doing Linguistics
are you solving the problem of how
language works and I'm like no I'm just
doing Technology and Engineering I'm
trying to make a a practical
computational language that can
represent things in the world which is a
different problem than the problem of
explaining kind of how language Works in
our human brains it is not self-evident
that there is a way to explain how
language Works in our human brains it
could be the case that there's you know
100 billion neurons and they're all
firing in a certain way and the
collective effect happens to produce
words and that there's no better
narrative description of what's going on
than just to say I've got 100 billion
neurons firing and you have to look at
all you know those detailed firings in a
kind of computationally reducible way I
suspect there is a better description
and I think even what we're seeing with
the success of things like chat GPT is
showing us that there is it's giving us
even more of a clue that there is a a
definite kind of narrative theory of how
language Works in brains
um but uh you know there's this question
of language in the abstract language as
it relates to talking about things in
the world and language as it is
implemented in brains and then I suppose
languages that might be implemented on
computers these are all separate pieces
and what the correspondence between them
is is not clear I mean it's like when
you study the theory of flight you can
study birds or you can build planes and
those are slightly different branches
and the things you understand about the
theory of flight from uh from building
planes there are certain cases you're
interested in that in that situation you
know if you want to study the flight of
insects with all their elaborate kind of
you know the the wings meets when they
have their sort of backstroke and so on
that that's all
um
you know it's all a different kind of
thing than studying oh we just want to
know about fixed wings and you know the
the flow of air over fixed wings and so
on so you you end up having to ask about
different kinds of things
I think one of the things actually I was
just looking because I've been just
looking at a bunch of books about
um uh the sort of the theory of language
and semantics and so on the uh Noam
chomsky's original advisor zelig Harris
has an interesting book about kind of
the mathematical structure of language
um that uh really is I think more
mathematical than the things that for
example the early work that was done
that Trump scared in the mid-1950s
um I haven't really I haven't really
paused not to make too much of a pun of
that
um you know exactly what the direction
of zelik Harris was relative to what
chomsky's ended up doing Etc et cetera
et cetera I don't really know
um the mathematicization of language is
something that uh Billy sort of happened
in the 1950s although there were
precursors and things like the
sujukowitz
um uh what came into categorical
grammars which I think was the 1920s
1930s kind of time frame so there were
precursors of that there were deep
precursors in Antiquity
um of the construction of these of these
grammars and famously by Panini for for
Sanskrit but you know when you look at
these grammars it's a little bit hard to
tell that they really are formally
specified grammars because you know one
thing that happens in early grammar
books from Antiquity is it'll be like
well this is a valid sentence here and
these are examples of valid sentences
the cat said on the mat the the mat was
Sat On by the cat these kinds of things
these are valid sentences and other ones
are not valid sentences notice that that
grammatically the mat set on the sat on
the cat is a perfectly valid sentence it
just is not likely to be semantically
meaningful and by the way this whole
question about what is semantically
Meaningful and what is not uh you know
you end up getting well of course there
could be a mat that is sitting on a cat
um you know maybe in some version of
math and some version of sat and so on
but this is where what's interesting
about the construction of computational
language is that in building wolfen
language for example
um what what we've done is to take
general concepts and lock them into very
definite things that have a documented
meaning and actually evaluate so you
know the function Plus in Wilson
language has a definite meaning where
you can actually it actually adds
numbers together and so on it isn't
something that is just a word plus that
might be you know the plus-sized version
of something or whatever else it is
using the word plus as a kind of a a
flag to say as a as a as a an indicator
of what the actual operation of this
thing that we call us is this really
hard computationally defined thing
that's called plus is we're we're
leveraging the fact that there is an
English word plus but we're then making
a more precise meaning to that that word
and I think that's a a general approach
which one can expect to use uh and and
um
in kind of going from the the merely you
know this is from the merely linguistic
so to speak where the word plus can have
many meanings to the the truly kind of
computational and precise but still
making use of the fact that we're using
a word that is sort of recognizable to
people
um
that's interesting it's some
uh
see how it's coming too well the next
generation of chat GPT voice GPT have
any negative recourse especially when it
comes to impersonation well I mean uh
you know
I haven't yet heard
really good I mean you know even maybe
three years ago there were
um voice style transfer Networks
just as there have been image style
transfer networks for probably four
years or so now the voice ones were
still very CPU intensive and not very
good I haven't I haven't heard one
recently I'm sure that uh voice
impersonation uh will become something
that can readily be done it it would be
will be tremendously surprising if it
couldn't I mean the truth is even
whenever you are decompressing an MP3
file you're making use of these uh these
things which are essentially models of
the human vocal tract you're essentially
you know you're you're representing a
sound by uh kind of um parameters that
correspond to physical features of the
human vocal tract that's not that
doesn't need to be that way but that's a
convenient way to do it and so that's
that's sort of a compression that's
analogous to some kind of
um uh
um some kind of uh sort of narrowing
that happens in neural Nets and so on
and that is the way that one basically
gets a style transfer as you sort of
narrow things down so that you've you've
captured the essential essence of the
thing and then you then you pull it back
out again
um in in the new style and that's the
thing that one's already doing in some
sense in uh uh not for that purpose
quite in in some of uh audio compression
kinds of things so I I fully expect that
that will work
um the question of how realistic the the
kind of the bot version of me or
whatever will sound
um well the voice I'm sure will be
nailed up but you know that will be that
will be getable the the kind of the the
you know the How would how would I
answer this question and um you know
generating the words I don't know how
well that will work uh people have shown
me things from maybe six months ago from
earlier versions of gpg3 which were not
particularly good for as representations
of me
um and uh I am
uh we'll we'll see we'll see how long it
takes to get how good and how long it
can kind of keep going you know for a
sentence or two I think it will not be
too hard for a whole long monologue well
I don't know
um I I'd like to think that um there are
sort of features of that that are not
just the sort of the the mean of the
population plus a little bit added from
the particular ways that that I do
things but that I don't know
um
they call it from Igor here about
um uh can a submarine swim which
apparently in in English those words
don't work that way apparently in
Japanese they do I don't know that
um it's uh uh you know there are words
in English a single word can have many
meanings if that one can even see in
some machine learning kinds of things
with rather nice one can actually see
the different sort of places where the
word can be embedded in a sentence and
one can actually sort of draw a feature
space platform of language it would be
feature space plot and then you can
label it with uh you can you can cluster
it you can actually see here's a blob of
of meanings of of this word that are
over here and here's a completely
different meaning over here that's
visibly a different blob in feature
space so you get to see that with
English words that there that there will
be a single word and it has multiple
different multiple distinct meanings
um
there's a question from Zero D about do
I think AI represents an existential
risk how could we mitigate it you know I
think that
uh
what can I say about this I mean AI is a
form of Automation and the
there are many things at all stages and
and sort of the the Tower of automation
that we built in the world
um we can end up with a sort of bad
things happening
I think in the case of AI it's sort of a
question
of
I mean the you know lots of bad things
can happen with AI
um and lots of stupid decisions could be
made where we say uh let's just have a
machine decide that and the uh and some
you know it's it's a complicated thing
because
one is automating human judgment and and
often one is doing a reasonably good job
of reproducing what human judgments
would be now you can ask questions like
do we like the way that that thousand
times human judgment you know that that
all those iterations of human judgment
do we like it that it always does this
this sort of uh this thing that is a
reflection of of actual observed human
judgment do we like that or we might say
societally we don't like that even
though it is making the right judgment
in the sense that it is taking the input
and it is coming to the correct
conclusion even to a conclusion that
would be the majority conclusion uh the
you know the typical conclusion of
humans given the same task we might say
well actually when we can actually see
it plain and it's a machine that's doing
it we don't like what it's doing there
and I think you know the the ultimate
issue is always that in the end the
machine doesn't have an intrinsic this
is what I'm trying to do that has to be
provided by the the setter of goals
which for the time being is us I mean
there can be a time it's worth
understanding there can be a time where
there is a society of the machines where
the machines are all doing their thing
there are plenty of machines just sort
of doing their thing right now and
that's happening quite independent of
what we humans are doing but we have an
incredibly good analogy for that which
is what happens in the natural world the
natural world just does what it does
according to the rules it follows and we
humans are sometimes we interact with it
sometimes we perturb it sometimes we are
subject to what hap you know what what
what happens in it and so on but it's
its own thing and we might say well
we're going to create this Society of
the machines and you know we have
control troll over that it's it's it is
true up to a point but once we've set
these things in motion we've defined
their rules their rules say they're
going to do this and this and this
that's what they'll do just like natural
laws say that the natural world Works in
this or that way and I think the issue
is uh we will certainly get to a point
we are already at a point where many
things that happen in the Machine World
so to speak are not readily
understandable to us humans but you know
it's the same thing in the natural world
plenty of stuff that happens in the
natural world is not understandable to
us humans and so I think that's a
somewhat analogous situation now you
know it's really a question in some
cases well do you want to set up uh you
know how much if you have a choice are
you setting up some aspect of society to
work according to kind of the the whims
of the Society of machines or not and
you think oh we put our own you know we
put ourselves into these machines so we
will be able to know what comes back and
we'll be able to say we're going to like
it and so on that's really not
realistically what's going to happen you
know computational irreducibility makes
it completely clear that whatever you
know you set up the rules for the
machines we will never be able to
foresee all the consequences of these
rules and so then you know we can say
well we don't like the fact that you
know we're going to put some some
limiter on where the machines are able
to operate as compared to where we want
sort of humans in the loop and that gets
even more complicated when you have kind
of the the humans with the neural
implants that are that are you know
providing machine like Auto suggestions
about what to do and so on it becomes
even more complicated to sort of
untangle how that works
I think um uh
let's see the um
the the the yeah I mean these questions
about
um look I think there are many questions
which I certainly don't know the answer
to
um but they're they're quite many cases
immediate questions about sort of the um
uh the relationship between Ai and
society and the uh you know immediate
questions of things like
um you're trying to decide what guard
rails to put around chat gbt when it's
talking about things you know should you
tell it to not you know should you tell
it to you it might be a reasonable thing
to say only produce G-rated you know
essays might be another reasonable thing
to say you know don't say things that
will upset people
that gets very complicated
you know who you're going to upset you
might upset people by not saying things
that would upset other people it's a
it's a you know it's it's a hopeless
chain of you know how do you make it you
know in the end the only the only chat
bot that will offend nobody is the chat
bot that says nothing maybe even that
would offend people the uh so you know
it I think it's it's an unrealistic you
know you can try and make it uh you can
try and make it Bland
um but I I don't even think I think it
will be even across different cultures
blandness is not
constant so what might seem Bland in one
culture might seem utterly offensive in
in another one you know sort of the same
words and so on so you know I think that
that um this question of kind of how do
we how do we Define what it is we want
and you can pick any one of a whole
collection of different things I think
you know a search engine you know what
links should it put up there a um uh a
social media platform what what things
should it put in a feed these are all
sort of what are you choosing now the
chatbot case a little bit more extreme
because it is more from its own mind so
to speak it is less like let's pick
content that people have already
produced or let's say it's a you know a
generative AI image system you know what
kind of things should it be able to
produce should it be able to produce
what if it produces some incredibly
shocking picture
um you know should it be able to do that
what should you tell it about about
producing shocking or non-shocking
pictures what should you tell us about
producing pictures that have you know
sort of real people in the in them doing
terrible things or whatever else you
know what what should its principles be
and how do you define that
I think it's really hard but I think you
know one place that you start to get to
is let's just sort of write down laws
write down constraints that we want
these things to operate under and maybe
you come in at the end and you say let's
look at this picture do you want to
consider it shocking or not going in at
the beginning and saying let's tweak the
rules to never make a shocking picture I
think that's that's hopeless I think
that's a sort of computational
irreducibility hopelessness case
um when it comes to stating the rules
well you know where do you get the rules
from in a sense you know what we have
learned in the history of of the last
four thousand years or so more than that
of of uh of human law making so to speak
is that you know in the end you write
down kind of uh in some sense what you
want the constraints to be whether it's
the Code of Hammurabi or a modern you
know us code or a continental legal
system or whatever
um the uh
um it's you know there is a certain
thing that you describe now one of the
things that's nice and something we've
been interested in with wolf and
language for a while is kind of the
computational language description of
sort of what you want to have happen the
you know having a computational language
that can talk enough about the what's
what's really there in the world
um to be able to specify those
constraints in that computational
language the feature of that is once you
have the thing written in this
computational language it allows you to
have something which you can say you can
hold it up and you can say this is our
code so to speak and code not in the
sense of of well it would also be
computer code but this is this is these
are the things that we're operating
according to now you know there have
been experiments and blockchains and so
on of you know things like Dows
distributed autonomous organizations
where people try and say let's just
Define all the rules for how this is
going to work in code and that's ended
up very badly in certain cases
um because it was not foreseen what all
the possibilities would be and it was
not foreseen that there would be some
particular way that somebody could you
know transfer lots of money to
themselves in a way that everybody
thought was shocking and so on so I
think that um uh
um you know I consider this as far as
I'm concerned this very unresolved
issues and um you know in a sense you
can ask questions like what I've been
curious about I have no good answer so
let me say that up front is uh sort of
now that we have this kind of ability
potentially to be able to write
computational language that describes
human preferences to what extent can we
are there new forms of governance that
we can imagine given that capability
just like in the case of oh I don't know
you know your average democracy
situation it's like you know a multiple
choice thing you're saying pick this or
that or that and some and some vote that
you might give well
you could imagine a much more nuanced
situation where everybody is writing a
computational essay about what they want
and you're saying to some AI take all
these computational essays combine them
and figure out what what should happen I
think this is a you know I mean you just
get thrust immediately into issues of
very old issues of political philosophy
as you think about how's that AI
supposed to work what's its governing
principle for how it deals with all
those preferences does it make you know
one percent of the people super happy
and 95 of the people only medium happy
and three and four percent of the people
super unhappy what does it do how does
it decide what to do you know what are
its overarching governing principles and
I think we don't know that and and there
is no that that is not something which
came with the package for us humans is
the is the statement of and this is how
that has to work you know the only thing
that sort of comes with the package is
don't do stuff which makes the species
go extinct because then there's nothing
else to discuss about it you know if you
do if you if you do things badly enough
that um you know eventually uh there's
there's no there's nobody left to
discuss what's going on then then you
can say well that's a I probably say
that's a bad outcome maybe you don't say
that's a bad outcome maybe it's like the
the chat bot that says nothing is the
only good chat bot the uh uh you know
the the civilization that doesn't exist
is the only civilization which will do
nothing wrong
um uh you know that's a that's a uh that
that could be the that could be true
um not very useful but true
so
let's see
let's see Kat is asking how do I think
that Einstein or Stephen Hawking would
react to chat gbt
are there figures in science who
predicted this development
um look I mean everybody is who's
thought about this stuff has thought
this will eventually happen I have to
say it's happened more suddenly than I
expected I think language and linguistic
communication may be a little thinner
than we had imagined I mean the the idea
of um uh the idea that it would be
eventually possible and the path to get
to kind of statistically generated
plausible texts is it's not been clear
how well that will work and even a year
ago it really didn't work very well I
mean chat GPT I think is a mixture of a
an interesting underlying language model
together with some pretty good
engineering about how to actually
present it so that it doesn't like get
stuck in a loop and and has patterns of
output and so on it's a well-packaged
example of a sort of that core
methodology you know I think uh this
whole idea of generative AI systems and
generative computational systems well
this is a certainly something you know
that this is an old Story I mean in in
my own work and like Cellular automata
in the early 80s of generating images
which are surprisingly kind of
naturalistic even though they come from
Simple Rules even though they're very
much a pure computational origin that's
kind of an example then in in the early
2000s when we made this world from tones
website that produces some kind of
Musical 4 forms again that's something
where it is not okay so so in the case
of of something like uh you know chat
GPT it is uh sort of taking some kind of
statistical average of all of those
billions of documents that it found on
the web
in the case of cellular automata or
Wolfram tones what one is more doing is
creating from scratch using the same
principles as for example the natural
world uses to create structure but not
using the big Corpus of kind of human
memory and human uh and and sort of
human examples of of language
um but it was perfectly possible to
produce things which at least locally
were sort of plausible you know small
scale musical form for example sort of
just plucked from this computational
universe of possibilities without a big
loop that makes use of kind of human
experience and so on the only place The
Human Experience comes in is in the
picking of styles and so on once one has
generated some underlying structure so I
think the
the idea that sort of the statistical
language uh statistical use of language
could produce something that will be
coherent over the length of a small
essay is interesting I mean it's sort of
ironic that Alan Turing in 1950 talked
about this kind of touring test of can
we talk to a machine like we talk to a
person I think he thought about that as
a very rule-based kind of thing I mean
he'd been thinking about you know chess
playing machines and he was very much
and and much earlier he'd been thinking
about Turing machines and very much this
kind of rule-based structure for what
the thing should do ironically enough
during the second world war When Alan
Turing was working on cryptanalysis one
of his bigger contributions had to do
with the statistics of language of
knowing you know of all the sort of code
all the passwords that might be being
used how do you tell whether the the how
do you automatically tell whether with
that password the thing that's being
generated is actually a genuine piece of
German or whether it's just random
gibberish and the what he noted and and
that sort of I think turned into in some
ways information Theory and Claude
Shannon's stuff and so on I don't know
we don't know what the precise causal
chain there was
um but uh uh you know Turing invented
this kind of these ideas and sort of the
statistics of language as used for
cryptanalysis and so on and it's sort of
ironic that I don't think he made any
connection between that work which was
probably still secret which was still
Secret at the time among other things
and the things he was thinking about
about sort of AI and so on and I think
it remains unclear whether you know that
there is a the statistical uh character
of uh things like large language models
and so on is is is it's interesting that
it works as well as it does whether that
will be the way that we can really take
advantage of sort of the computational
Paradigm I'm not sure I think that
that's a way of taking advantage of some
aspect effects of of computation it's
not clear that we can build as big a
tower there as we can in in kind of
thinking about things in sort of a
precise computational way I mean I I
just wrote this thing a couple of days
ago about uh using Wolfram Alpha which
is based on kind of actually turning
having a symbolic representation of the
world and Computing things precisely
from that connecting that to chat GPT
and it's rather lovely because Chachi PT
can formulate questions that can be
answered by the natural language
understanding system of Wolfram Alpha or
can be turned by the natural language
understanding system into precise
symbolic representation of things where
the answers can be got and then chat GPT
is seems to be mostly uh rather
dignified in if you tell it oh here's a
thing you might use to correct this
essay or whatever else it very much it
almost says you know okay thanks and I'm
I'm going to use it and then it produces
another another version of the essay
um it is it is however a little bit
remarkable when you when you think to
yourself that what it's actually doing
underneath just running this neural net
a word at a time or a token at a time
which is sometimes a piece of a word and
it's just saying what's the
statistically likely thing to come next
and that's it and it's kind of shocking
to think that you know brains probably
work very much like that too and I think
uh you know there's not sort of more
magic to it
um
let's see
huh interesting comment from William
here given what we've learned from AI
models does learning from history allow
us to better predict the future does
modeling the past and play modeling the
future
interesting question that's an
interesting question so I mean the fact
that a Transformer net will successfully
learn the pattern of of uh of lots of
things on the web and be able to make
reasonable essay statements a good
question is that's a good question if
you feed it the knowledge of human
history
and you ask it to predict the future
based on its knowledge of human history
to what extent will the patterns that it
finds be such that it will successfully
predict history
you know the thing that I suppose is is
in a sense what I'm asking about when
talking about Aristotle and logic and
and that kind of explainable pattern
there's sort of a question of whether
you know a training of a transformer net
for example can discover patterns that
we have never noticed before and that
are sort of perhaps even Indescribable
by any of the words and the narrative
that we currently have and the answer is
it probably is finding some such
patterns there may be a future logic in
quotes that is kind of that that
captures those patterns that it's found
in a way that is now narratively
explainable so now the question is is
there sort of a theory of history is
there a pattern of history I mean I
think um uh is the um
um
I think Hegel is famous for having
talked about sort of theories of history
and and uh the sort of necessary flow of
history and that got um it got picked up
by um
both very sort of left-wing and very
right-wing
um political efforts
um but I think that the um uh
um
this question if it's a sort of a flow
to human history a predictable flow to
human history interesting question and
the answer is probably yes I mean I know
people talk about
um you know various kinds of uh
the you know theories of oh when uh when
us when a when a particular society gets
uh sort of quite old it builds up more
and more bureaucracy and its governance
and things like this and and eventually
this and that happens I mean this is
kind of the the um the concept of Isaac
asimov's kind of psycho-history idea of
kind of there is a
a predictable flow to history you know I
think computational irreducibility kind
of tells you on a smaller scale at least
there isn't a flow to history you know I
was I was just looking at um
uh
I was just looking actually at a book
um by uh Charles Darwin's
son grandson not sure maybe grandson
um there is a book called the next
million years that's published in the
1950s and I I just got as far as the
introduction to the book but what it
says is predicting the next 10 years is
really hard it says but it says maybe
just like we can discuss gas molecules
bouncing around in a box in a gas and we
can't necessarily say where the
individual gas molecules are going to go
but we can say collectively what's going
to happen to all the molecules in the in
the Box we can use the gas laws to do
that so maybe if we try and predict
history on a time scale of a million
years it is more predictable says this
this Darwin than than it might be on a
10-year time scale and I suppose that's
an interesting question is whether the
sort of the overall Arc of human history
has a certain predictability to it you
know it's interesting we haven't in in
language we have day data on the the
borders of it all known historical
countries and you can kind of make an
animation I've kind of particularly
Europe where there's a lot of data and a
lot of structure there of what's
happened to the borders of countries in
Europe over the last couple of thousand
years and what you see is something
that's very it looks very physical or
maybe biological you know you'll see
some region it gets bigger and bigger
and bigger somebody's making a bigger
and bigger Empire and then pop that
bubble bursts that disappears other
things move in its place it kind of
reminds one of you know a froth of soap
bubbles and things of all the borders of
these countries where every border every
motion of every border was a lot of
human lives and a lot of uh you know a
lot of a lot of kind of Human Experience
there but when you look at it in the
large-scale aggregate it looks kind of
like something where you'd say oh there
might be an equation that describes the
motion of all these things with a
certain amount of of of of unpredict
predictable Randomness to it it seems
like there might be sort of a a global
theory of the kind of the ebb and flow
of countries
um whether and that that kind of
supports the this is this kind of
question of whether on a large scale on
sort of the large statistical scale are
there things that can be said about the
patterns of human history and you know
to us living day to day it seems
implausible that such a thing would
happen but you know you imagine you're a
gas molecule and you're kind of
colliding with other ones and so on and
it might be implausible that you could
predict the very large-scale structure
of the whole gas but maybe you can I
would suspect that there isn't enough
human history to be able to use those
kinds of you know very large scale kind
of uh arguments and and conclusions my
guess is that that there just aren't
enough you know there's a couple hundred
countries in the world today they've
been comparable numbers throughout most
of History well when it was in a kind of
city-state World there were probably
probably more maybe more of them Maybe
not maybe they're about the same number
because the population was a lot smaller
I'm not sure but you know being able to
predict what will happen on a on a very
large time scale
um we may just not have a large enough
time scale it may we may still be
operating in the world it really
mattered that the Roman Empire extended
this far these specific features of
particular particulars of history may
still have enough effect and you know
hence the you know can we predict the
next million years well I think I think
we generally believe that the Human
Experience will not remain the same uh
you know as as we as we reach the point
where we have uh you know in the time in
the night even the 1950s it wasn't clear
the notion of kind of a a virtual
existence and digital you know sort of
Souls and digital form and and you know
effective immortality and so on those
were not really on the horizon at that
time they are now and uh you know
exactly what consequences that will have
the the future of History doesn't feel
like it will be similar to the Past in
history but there may be certain
patterns of any any sort of any
Consciousness any any sort of entity
that's kind of like us in certain ways
um will have some necessary pattern of
of large-scale History it could very
well be the case and one of the things
that has come out in our physics project
is the realization that entities that
observers like us who are
computationally bounded who believe that
we're persistent in time that it is a
necessary feature of being an observer
like us that you will observe that the
Universe follows the laws of gravity and
quantum mechanics and so on so it could
be the case that if we can tighten up
that idea of observers like us and go
beyond computationally bounded and uh uh
persistent in time but have some other
aspects of the essence of The Human
Condition I don't know what those would
be I mean these are sort of some kind of
you know base ethical something or other
thing or some other feature of the human
condition that that when when you put
those into the mix that it will be
inevitable that the very large scale
flow of History has some particular form
that there will be sort of an inevitable
bulk theory of history that will always
be the case for any organisms that have
a particular format it kind of makes me
wonder if you look at it for organisms I
don't like ants or something like this
or some some even lower organism where
you have an Ecology of of those
organisms uh you know what are the
large-scale things you can say and and
generally in ecology there are pretty
weak things that people end up ending up
being able to say about total population
numbers and ratios of this and that and
so on uh you know is there one might ask
a more detailed thing to say if you were
a little microorganism living your life
in in this um uh in this Colony big
colony of microorganisms would there be
uh is there is there more detail that
one can give than to just say it's this
number of microorganisms and I suppose
that's a that's an interesting question
of kind of what the analog what the bulk
limit of
um uh you know individual sort of lives
of in an ecology actually end up being
all right well let's see
um I should probably wrap up here uh
but that's an interesting interesting
question what the what what one can kind
of learn you know is there a a theory of
History
uh I think this whole question of is
there a theory of x
there's sort of two levels of that one
is are there rules one can write down
that describe the microscopic underlying
structure of X that's one thing and then
when one looks at the large-scale kind
of Contours of what happens
um are there humanly understandable
versions I mean in a sense the whole
Enterprise of Natural Science has to do
with saying are there kind of ways to
connect what we see happening in nature
with what uh with what we can think
about in our minds with what we can kind
of stuff into our minds the whole story
of kind of computational irreducibility
there are things that happen in nature
you just have to essentially watch them
happen and see how they unfold that's
kind of not a that that is a necessary
that is something that's necessary that
is a paradigmatically uh correct kind of
thing but it's something that kind of
denies the possibility of a certain kind
of Natural Science and when one says is
there a theory of such and such a thing
it's really asking come on go come
someone sort of break out of
computational irreducibility and find
some slice of reducibility uh
the um
yeah Edmond is commenting about ants
um that they're that they're structured
succinctly enough that one could lead to
conclusions on many levels yeah I mean
certainly one you know one watches ants
doing their thing and uh uh it's uh you
know I I there are some theories I know
of kind of overall sort of ant behavior
and so on of you know the ant sees the
neighboring ants and it has certain
certain Behavior based on that
um I I just don't know what what
statements can be made that go beyond
kind of the almost mechanical statement
about the you know when you have a
collection of ants or a flock of birds
or a school of fish we know that there
are certain characteristics that those
those uh Collective characteristics that
those groups of organisms will have
um that uh in which we know that there's
you know various kinds of flocking
behavior where where things will all
arrange themselves in a definite sort of
lump and then then something will happen
and the lump will turn and and how that
turn works and so on that's all stuff we
have some understanding of and the main
understanding is there's only local
information that you know you're just
the fish is just looking at somewhat
neighboring fish and yet once the leader
fish decides we're going to make a turn
then then you know all the other fish
kind of cascade down and and see they're
going to make a turn and so on and we
can describe something about that but it
will be interesting to understand is
there a is there a larger scale thing
one could say you know for example yes
the school of fish is schooling in this
way but what can you say about the
large-scale set of decisions that it
makes about where to go is it a purely
random walk is it something else what
can be said is there a kind of a larger
scale theory of what's going on there
and I you know I think um uh again I I
don't know
um
what that's really like or whether
whether we reached the point I mean
we're we're kind of spoiled with gas
molecules because they're an awful lot
you know they're a trillion trillion gas
molecules in a little box this size and
you know when it comes to the kinds of
things we've been thinking about in our
physics project and we look at sort of
the atoms of space there are just
absurdly large numbers of atoms of space
in some fairly small region and so we
really can talk about these large-scale
limits it's less obvious whether that
will really work in these in these kind
of issues of human Affairs and so on
all right we should wrap up there well
thanks for for raising all kinds of um
uh interesting topics
um and uh
I see questions about completely
different kinds of topics which I look
forward to addressing another time
well thanks for joining me and uh uh see
you another time